[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24
consacrait à la sécurité au mali et au
sahel à partir ou rester s le dilemme
qui s'impose à la france au mali alors
que ce débat s'immisce dans la campagne
électorale que représente la force
wagner dans le pays quelle est cette
ombre russe qui plane sur le mali que
cherche vladimir poutine en afrique le
sahel est il une poudrière djihadistes
on va en discuter avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir avec nous cyril payen
journaliste à france 24 grand reporter
qui revient tout juste du mali bonsoir
cyril on va regarder votre reportage
d'ailleurs avant le début de cette
émission wassim nassr avec nos
spécialistes des mouvements djihadistes
sur france 24
bienvenue voici ma michel goya est avec
nous bonsoir ancien officier des troupes
marine docteur en histoire contemporaine
hauteur du c'est le dernier en tout cas
le temps des guépards la guerre mondiale
de la france de 1961 à nos jours et
c'est aux éditions est tallandier
bienvenue à vous michel goya et merci
d'être avec nous on va regarder donc
votre reportage cyril cyril payen vous
venez de revenir et c'est un reportage
qui s'intitule l'ombre russe au mali on
regarde
[Musique]
20 janvier 2022 c'est le jour des forces
armées au mali jour de consécration pour
un gouvernement de transition pour les
postes clés sont occupés depuis deux ans
par des officiers putschistes
voici le nouvel homme fort du pays
assimi higuita un colonel des forces
spéciales de 39 ans porté au pouvoir par
la rue malienne le colonel éternise la
transition et art d'aujourd'hui à
organiser des élections démocratiques
et depuis quelques semaines le mali sous
embargo régional était la croisée des
chemins pris d'une poussée de fièvre
nationaliste et panafricaniste
les alliés d'hier dont la france qui
déploient des milliers de soldats depuis
près de dix ans dans une force anti
jihadistes sont supplantés au profit des
nouveaux arrivants le problème de la
sécurité du mali d'un problème majeur
parce que sans cela tout ne marche pas
la chine bien sûr va travailler dans le
sens de rapprocher les le mali et les
cdo qu'on va trouver un consensus pour
trouver une solution 2 du règlement de
la crise
la délégation russe n'est pas très
loquace mais elle est acclamée par la
foule
vive la liste
[Musique]
bamako rive droite quartier de kalaban
coura nous sommes dans la maison de
mohamed 30 ans qui est né et a grandi
dans la capitale malienne comme beaucoup
ici mohamed est un ardent supporter du
pouvoir militaire
cela qui a accouché en bas à lui ségal
kokalla maïga
c'est l'autre qui est l'autre côté il
s'appelle à ce niveau et à l'autre que
j'ai de tout ce qui a poussé la
balustrade du canada ces deux personnes
qui me plaît beaucoup et c'est leur
succès no 6 a poussé là j'ai redonné le
monde de la nuit le daily mail a révélé
sur les allergies la défense
depuis le père fondateur de
l'indépendance
ils ont subi un idéal cet idéal c voire
l'émancipation des peuples africains
et moi je m'inscris dans cette optique
pour pouvoir mieux aborder ce combat et
voir l'épanouissement général des
peuples africains bon c'est que nous
avons vu avec la france de 2012 jones a
fait 9 ans ils sont ainsi avec quels
résultats tous les jours c'est des pics
et des villages qui sont brûlés devant
l'enceinte assassines et boules vif des
enfants et tué sa poussée dans nous
voulons diversifier nos partenariats
même sort contre l'ingérence ce qu'on
veut pas que quelqu'un d'autre pays que
ce soit la france n'est autre pays
viennent nous imposer leur foi
nous sommes le 22 janvier et c'est une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation dans
les rues de bamako une semaine
auparavant des centaines de milliers de
maliens ont répondu à l'appel du pouvoir
et sont descendus dans les rues du pays
pour dénoncer les sanctions régional qui
frappe le pays
ce nouveau rassemblement est organisé
par le groupe y est rigolo debout sur
les remparts le noyau dur des jeunesses
nationalistes malienne la manifestation
tourne rapidement à la diatribe anti
françaises
[Musique]
bon
dommage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'entends tu as le sentiment de
fierté sentiment de patriotisme qui m'a
même demandé comme ça vraiment je suis
la manière des peuples africains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sow
oh
le cortège de plusieurs milliers de
manifestants pendant de longues heures
faire le tour de la ville en gonflant
ses rangs
[Musique]
ça a été une réussite totale
mal y pense en tout cas
je suis encore merci
[Musique]
à robin li aujourd'hui sont les voix qui
s'élèvent contre ces mouvements
souverainistes
[Musique]
c'est qu'il ne jure que par la russie
pour moi s'est soldée malienne manipuler
nous sommes vraiment manipuler j'en veux
pour preuve les autorités actuelles à en
déplacer les débats ils sont allés si
l'intérêt des manipulations des débats
c'est juste le respect du délai de la
transition
ce sont ces manipulations là qui pousse
certains à soutenir les autorités de la
transition pour
exiger l arrivée des mercenaires ou même
de la russie
le jeune militaire qui n'aiment pas
aller au front combattre les terroristes
profitent a souvent des blocages pour
essayer de renverser le régime
démocratiquement élu et une fois arrivés
au pouvoir ils n'hésiteront pas à
venir
combattre les terroristes
ces mercenaires ce sont les
paramilitaires du groupe wagner bras
armé de l' influence russe à l'étranger
syrie libye mozambique centrafrique et
depuis peu mali la question de la
présence militaire russe est à bout
ce lanceur d'alert prend d'énormes
risques en nous emmenant vers l'aéroport
militaire de bamako où les forces russes
se réinstaller
l'aéroport là une zone réservée au
contingent russe veut n'y a pas très
longtemps il ya la mini sma il ya
également les femmes et à des routes
étaient fermées
c'est mme d
donc on ne voit pas de contingent russe
ils savent que les maliens sont divisés
sur le sujet il ya beaucoup de
partenaires qu'ils n'accepteront jamais
que des paramilitaires jeunes à
combattre à leurs côtés il ya cette
raison pour laquelle les lampes a
beaucoup profité ils savent aussi que
sada magna
héritier du premier président modibo
keita elles sont également en lice que
pour
la défense de l'intégrité du territoire
dob normalement arriver ni une femme
là où vous voyez les installations des
antennes
dans tous les sens
cela ou de charge elle même
au moment de le décharger il ya fois en
toute discrétion
c'est dans cette base que seraient
regroupés les forces russes wagner ou
forces conventionnelles coopérant le
doute persiste
quoi qu'il en soit nous dirons pas plus
loin
sur fond de guerre froide virtuel la
présence de la milice russe est
largement entretenue dans la guerre
informationnelle que se livrent les
puissances d'hier et d'aujourd'hui comme
en attestent ses vidéos de propagande
qui pullulent sur les réseaux sociaux
malien si on vous place au sommet du
monde le groupe paramilitaire russe
wagner compte intervenir sur le sol
malien avec 4500 hommes qui seront
déployés à partir du 11 novembre
prochain dans la bande sahélo saharienne
et dont la mission consistera à lutter
contre le terrorisme et à soutenir les
forces réglementaire du mali et de ses
voisins à faire face aux défis
sécuritaires dans la région et les
nîmoises qui sont moins que david ne
sont pas vrai
parce que c'est des images
alou diallo et ses confrères blogueurs
passent leurs journées à traquer les uns
fox qui parasitent la toile et polarise
dangereusement le débat public au mali
avec
les coudes et à l'abaissement des
mythiques son couloir avec ses
nationalisme en juillet mais qui voilà
qui prend la force et cette tension
diplomatique entre la chaîne métro m'a
dit et les autorités françaises cette
piste de mala au palace un défaut
d'information dans chaque partie et
c'est vraiment de barbara rampillon
direction cathy la ville garnison des
hauteurs de bamako c'est ici qu'ont
souvent été fomenté les nombreux putschs
au mali le dernier en date n'échappe pas
à la règle
mohamed est un fils et frère de soldat
cathy est le berceau de sa famille
[Musique]
cette collaboration avec la russie
vraiment que pendant dix ans après il ya
l'armée française et toutes les autres
forces qui sont ici le résultat c'est
mme assana ça n'a rien donné et à
quelques mois de l'arrivée des russes
les femmes en ont commencé à avoir des
résultats sur les terrains peu partout
frémin qui veulent la collaboration
entre le mali et la kz et puis elle dit
aussi que vraiment assimile tout leur
soutien
et comment tu arrives à rester quand
même assez modérée parce que tu vois
tout le monde est un peu énervé au mali
en ce moment au burkina faso en guinée
et toi tu arrives à être modérée qu'est
ce qui fait la différence avec toi
c'est à dire que les gens comprennent
que la vie politique française et la
population francilienne sciences de la
vie politique malienne
malienne social malienne il ya une
petite différence
c'est la thune amène la profession
voilà malentendu confusion mais aussi
des pays au bord de la rupture alors que
le mali et ses nouveaux alliés pousse la
france vers la sortie cette nouvelle
voie malienne qui se propage chaque jour
un peu plus au sahel est aussi un saut
dans l'inconnu pour des millions
d'habitants d'afrique de l'ouest il aura
partage cyril payen cyril qui est avec
nous série alors justement est ce que
cette ombre russe plane sur le mali
c'est un peu ce que vous montrez dans le
reportage bah oui la question c'est
quelle nature à cette ombre en ce qui
concerne la rumeur sous secret de
polichinelle dont le sait delà des
parallèles la présente pendant des
paramilitaires de wagner cela émaner
d'une dépêche de reuters en août dernier
et depuis on a effectivement des
informations je n'ai pas vu j'ai fait
trois séjours au mali ces deux derniers
mois je n'ai pas vu de paramilitaires de
wagner ça reste encore une fois on est
vraiment dans une guerre
informationnelle ce qui est semble assez
intéressant sur le sur le terrain c'est
que la diplomatie veut le bras armé
diplomatique de du soft power degrés
divers poutine n'a finalement pas
nécessairement besoin d'avoir des
centaines de paramilitaires de wagner
puisque le fantasme toute cette
propagande se fait naturellement dans il
ya certainement des opérateurs qui sont
venus de centrafrique notamment qui
encadrent dès qu'ils sont issus de
wagner et ça coûte cher les
paramilitaires de wagner donc on peut se
dire aussi sur le terrain qu'il y à des
militaires très conventionnel qui sont
notamment à la manoeuvre dans le dans le
centre mais c'est une ombre russe est un
spectre dont l'idée force et d'occuper
le terrain et de remplacer en termes d'
influence les les français michel goya
laure wagner a juste pour expliquer à
nos téléspectateurs seraient financées
par un oligarque russe evgeny prigogine
c'est des groupes paramilitaires
manifestement qu'on connaît depuis un
certain temps qui était en ukraine en
syrie même en libye est aujourd'hui donc
en afrique oui wagner c'est une société
privée comme la
finance et enfin appartenant à un proche
de vladimir poutine alors que le régime
lui même ni l'existence de sociétés
privées et nous communique absolument
pas sûr
sur elle mais c'est effectivement le
bras armé de la russie à l'étranger ça
lui permet de mener des missions
[Musique]
déjà des missions les plus dangereuses
c'est à dire que au lieu d'engager des
troupes conventionnelles dont les décès
ou ont fait l'objet d' événement bon ben
quand mercenaires de la teneur et tu
essaies à moins d'un impact politique
mais surtout ça permet d'agir d'agir
sans être présent officiellement donc
pas la russie comme équipe assure le
bali particulièrement alors que et c'est
ils ont véritablement des troupes sur le
terrain on sait qu'ils ont des troupes
sur le terrain oui au mali oui c'est cet
art
ou mercenaires oui sur la wii le
font-ils ils sont là pour protéger
justement tous les temps d'abord de leur
volume mais là aussi on parle de 300 600
ce qui en soi déjà n'est pas
stratégiquement très important c'est
avec ça qu'on va changer le cours de la
guerre ils peuvent être là pour encadrer
conseiller un peu ce que nous faisons
nous déjà où ce que font les différentes
missions européennes ils peuvent aller
au combat aussi le wagner peut s'engager
également au combat bon c'est pas en
vrai on verra mais toujours est il qu à
leur écoute ou simplement aussi
peut-être protéger servir un petit peu
de garde
prétorienne aux rimes c'est rodez pour
des gens pour qui la menace est autant
intérieur vient et d'un autre éventuel
renversement d'un coup d'état où l'armée
est peut-être également une menace
intérieure c'est le faire appel à des
mercenaires c'est aussi une sorte
d'assurance d'assurance vie voici
peut-être le spécialiste des mouvements
jihadistes crise bat contre les
djihadistes
pour le moment on a pu documenter un
seul affrontement où il y avait des
accompagnateurs russe russophone de la
malienne dans le centre manny sont
tombés dans un piège des djihadistes
d'al qaïda premières infos que j'ai pu
avoir c'est qu'il ya eu un blessé
russophone transporté à sévaré pour être
soigné et là on avait la confirmation
qu'ils étaient sur le terrain en tout
cas quand on l'a dit sert il les rumeurs
couraient depuis plusieurs mois déjà et
puis on a eu confirmation comme quoi il
ya un un receveur qui a été tué la vidéo
est limpide arrière qui montrait le
moment de la de l'iodé et l'ailé les
restes on va dire de cet homme qui ont
été retrouvés par les par les
djihadistes donc pour le moment il y
monte pas au combat en tout cas donc ils
sont en train d'accompagner l'armée
malienne en tant qu'instructeur pas en
tant qu éclaireurs c'est important parce
qu'on les a vus se déployer dans
d'autres pays par exemple pour parler de
wagner en particulier comme éclaireur
pour planter des fog en séries il allait
avec l'armée syrienne puis il y avait le
gros de troupes qui arrive et c'est pas
encore le cas à tombouctou a priori ce
sont des des mécanos de l'armée russe
qui viennent aider les maliens à rendre
opératif dernier hélico qu'ils ont
acheté rien d'exceptionnel les accords
c'est des accords bilatéraux entre pays
ça fait partie du contrat les munitions
et les et les mécanos mais comme l'a
très bien dit michel aussi c'est que le
propre de ce genre d'opération c'est que
ça ne fait en mode cool n'ose pas la
responsabilité ni la responsabilité des
exactions cyr n'a ni la responsable il
ya eu manifestement enfin pas au mali à
mai il ya eu déjà des exactions en
république centrafricaine nuit ni ni ni
les échecs y en a eu au mozambique ni au
cas où ils sont frappés la
responsabilité de réagir parce qu'elle
est un précédent en syrie où il y avait
des mercenaires wagner qui accompagne et
des miliciens sait rien et qui ont
essayé d'aller un peu plus loin dans le
territoire kurde les américains n'ont
pas hésité à les frapper et du coup
moscou sa responsabilité n'est pas
engagée ne s'est pas senti obligé de
répondre sur le terrain à ce moment-là
peut-être qu'ils ont répondu par
ailleurs mais c'est le propre de ce
genre de groupes d'activités que
d'ailleurs la france aussi faisait appel
à ça et encore et encore quelques
décennies on va dire et d'autres et
d'autres pays aujourd'hui c'est plus une
capacité occidentale aujourd'hui en tout
cas européenne les américains font
toujours ça et les russes le fond sans
jamais admettre évidemment cyril vous
parlais justement de cette influence
donc à cette présence militaire wagner
et puis y ait cette influence russe via
la désinformation y participe finalement
à ce sentiment anti français oui
effectivement encore là c'est facile de
plaquer le scénario soit africain où ils
sont à la manoeuvre avec enfin avec des
gros sabots si je puis dire est ce que
c'est le même scénario qu'on va voir
arriver au mali difficile à dire mais en
tout cas ça en prend vraiment vraiment
la tournure on a vu dans ce film un
extrait des vidéos des vidéos on en
parlait à l'instant il y en a des
centaines sur les réseaux sociaux qui
sont faciles à fabriquer mais qui ont
une répercussion et des conséquences
énormes sur des populations qui sont pas
nécessairement prête à interpréter de
l'information donc c'est on jette en
pâture des informations qui sont
totalement fausses et c'est absolument
bidon et d'ailleurs il ya quand même des
blogueurs au mali assez courageux pour
s'opposer à ce genre de josé puis les
décomposer mais sont-ils écouter mais en
tout cas le résultat est très simple
c'est ces manifestations qu'on a vus
c'était quand même le 14 janvier ses 450
mille personnes dans les rues de bamako
et dans d'autres rues de deux villes du
mali ce n'est pas courant à l'appel de
l'aja à l'aja du gouvernement de
transition qui dit on va défendre notre
souveraineté nous sommes engagés dans un
processus
panafricaniste donc tous ces mots clés
propagandistes très populiste parce
qu'au fond vers où on va personne ne le
sait vraiment mais on pointe les boucs
émissaires les silos aujourd'hui c'est
l'opération marque anne c'est
l'opération qui a près de près de dix
ans d'engagement anti djihadiste
français qui sans doute a fait date qui
sans doute a tardé à recevront
dimensionné mais ça c'est un autre débat
mais on est coincé dans un étau j'irai
pour la france et avec un saut dans
l'inconnu qui est basée uniquement sur
de la propagande à ce qu'on voit tous
les jours michel la présence de
mercenaires de la société privée wagner
au mali serait incompatible avec la
présence internationale et européenne a
averti jean yves le drian et ça c'était
le chef de la diplomatie une déclaration
du 16 septembre 2021 c'était vraiment la
france ou wagner on en est plus là
aujourd'hui alors dont il faut rappeler
quand même que le mali toujours eu des
liens avec la russie que des membres de
la junte ont été formés à moscou que
l'indépendance du pays le mali ne s'est
pas tourné vers la france mais vers
l'union soviétique à l'époque que comme
l'a souligné voici les grands partis de
leur équipement vient de russie tout
simplement donc il ya des biens et
accessoirement le mali est malgré tout
un pays souverain qui peut faire appel
là
qui n'importe quel partenaire c'est ce
qu'ils disent d'ailleurs si on sent une
certaine fierté dans le disque hanté au
mali mais dans d'autres pays aussi de
diversifier un petit peu l'idée de ne
plus dépendre forcément uniquement de
l'aide européenne on va dire et surtout
française très clairement mais la
réaction française qui a été de dire
c'est eux ou nous alors c'est mon sens
là aussi un franchissement enfin deux
sortes de lignes rouges qui n'était
peut-être pas forcément utile de placer
c'était se mettre dans une situation
difficile en revanche ce qui se passe
c'est que il ya un certain nombre de
pays européens notamment des pays
d'europe de l'est du pays baltes
l'estonie qui participent
à l'effort au mali qui participent à la
force d'un combat par exemple qui est en
train de se maquille en train de se
mettre en place et qui pour eux est
effectivement la présence de russes
à côté même si les territoires est
immense c'est dire chapeau c'est
difficilement compatible dans les
tableaux blancs et effectivement il y en
a déjà un certain nombre qui vont plus
oui il allait bien il ya déjà il ya des
visas prochain d'accrochages et sacro
avec diplomatique danemark mais un pays
comme la norvège a dit mal ça c'est
terminé mais après il est piqué
effectivement maintenant ce deviennent
très hésitant et on est ce que ça montre
michel goya la koala justement le fait
qu'il y ait aujourd'hui ses hésitations
qui est des retraits des forces danoises
oui on est à foumban et même pas nés
qu'on a l'impression qu'elle est elle
mort née pratique mais aujourd'hui la
france vous le dites est en difficulté
et encore plus par cette présence russe
bien sûr bien sûr mais on était en train
de transformer l'opération barkan alors
effectivement on l'a certainement trop
tardé à le faire au passage moi je
n'étais pas persuadé même que
l'opération barkan soit forcément une
bonne idée
l'idée de
cette opération s'était de contenir
l'ennemi les groupes jihadistes en
attendant que les forces sécurité
locales maliennes en particulier puisse
prendre le combat à leur compte c'est ça
le plan en 2014 la réalité c'est un plan
qui était extrêmement fragile qui était
très faible d'abord on n'a pas mis
forcément les moyens nous mêmes
initialement pour exercer cette pression
et puis ensuite il imaginer que l'armée
malienne allait se restructurer et
devenir une
force puissante capable de prendre le
combat à son compte c'était complètement
illusoire mais ce qui se passe c'est que
ça a été un peu évoqués dans le
reportage c'est pour les gens qui sont
sur place ils voient tous ces pays il
voit la france bien sûr mais voir les
terre pleins de pays ils sont dans au
mali il ya peut-être une trentaine de
pays dans la minus pas la fascination
judith l'eau la mission utm ses missions
de formation et le duo peine l'aforst à
kouba où maintenant il ya enfin de plus
que 10 maintenant nations qui sont là et
qu'ils m'attendent et cette trame nation
nation puissante vous avez beaucoup de
moyens vous avez des grosses machines
vous avez des avions c'est peut-être
comme ça et
vous combattez quelques milliers de
combattants camp et les rues de 9 ans il
ya les résultats sont extrêmement
faibles c'est les résultats sont
extrêmement faibles qui ne voient pas la
réalité que dans tout le temps il ya
très peu de nations qui combattent
réellement qu'il lance des opérations
contre les groupes dieu dit c'est
pourquoi pourquoi est elle un tel échec
si je peux dire face c'est parce que
cette menace est diffus c'est parce que
c'est beaucoup trop gros parce que la
stratégie à la base n'était pas la bonne
je pense que la stratégie n'était pas la
bonne au départ on était autant
l'intervention initiale l'opération
serval était cohérente et est efficace
ça on sait faire faire une opération de
pompiers d'éteindre un incendie avec des
objectifs clairs ça c'est si on peut le
faire on le fait même plutôt bien
servi a été un succès mais l'erreur
c'était de rester des restes et
notamment au mali c'est à dire rester au
coeur des problèmes et
sachant qu'on ne pouvait pas y rester
éternellement
jamais une opération militaire française
a duré plus de neuf ans quoi mais là on
arrive en limite moi j'ai expliqué il ya
deux ans déjà que la marque n avait deux
ans d'espérance de vie qu' il ya une
usure il ya des pertes ça coûte très
cher presque un ensemble de la présence
française ça coûte un milliard d'euros
chaque année donc il ya une usure
forcément et donc il fallait un moment
donné il fallait forcément se
transformer et sera adapté ce que l'on
était en train de faire de manière assez
progressive parce que c'est en se
désengage pas comme ça dans le
territoire après plusieurs années de
présence il saute ça demande des mois et
là ils disent et ce processus soit là
qui est maintenant mais remis en
question très fortement oui la france un
peu poussé dehors wassim justement où en
sont les mouvements djihadistes puisque
votre spécialité au mali parce qu'on
voit bien qu'ils aient effectivement un
échec ben il ya des réussites militaires
sur le terrain dans cette dynamique il
ya quand même le chef d'aqmi qui a été
tué le chef de terre amie qui a été tué
beaucoup de résultats sur le terrain les
opérations continuent même avec les
femmes 1 alors qu'on parle maintenant
malgré la pression
politique mais une fine et ya pas de
stratégie il ya pas de but final
recherché ça veut dire tuer des chefs
ce que les israéliens appelés la
tondeuse à gazon ça résout pas le
problème parce que les raisons
objectives qui ont fait que ces groupes
existent sont toujours là et les raisons
objectives sont antérieurs au groupe
djihadiste les objectifs c'est une
situation économique sans sans horizon c
d état prédateur s'est désarmé
prédatrice l'absence de définissent pour
faire finances avec très peu hein c'est
la microéconomie ça veut dire il se
finance sur les otages par exemple les
six ou plus pour faire une liste
grandeur le budget d'aqmi au sahel ça
tourne autour d'eux on va dire trois
millions trois millions cinq par an ok
un otage ses 6 millions en moyenne voilà
le calcul est vite fait sinon c'est la
microéconomie ça veut dire quand il ya
des trafics de gasoil ou de produits
ménagers les routes de trafic sont par
là les djihadistes axes les routes c'est
aussi simple que ça le bétail les taxes
le bétail voilà mais ce qui est
intéressant à savoir c'est que les gens
les djihadistes qui sont en face c'est
des gens qui réfléchissent aussi qu'ils
ont aussi un plan qui n'est pas en
concordance avec les plans français ils
ont juste leur plan c'est d'instaurer un
territoire qu'il contrôle de faire
régner un algérien et c'est ce qu'ils
font ils font de la politique admis
aujourd'hui al qaïda fait de la
politique y sont tellement imbriquées
dans le tissu social et économique
qu'ils sont devenus présent face à une
autre force qui est celle de l'état
islamique qui fait pas de politique et
dans cette équation beaucoup de gens
étaient obligés de choisir leur camp
donc ils choisissent leur camp le moins
dur on va dire en l'absence de l'état et
en la présence de barkan quelques heures
mais pas tout le temps et choisissent le
moins dure il ya des gens sur place qui
disent pourquoi par exemple ils laissent
pas al qaïda al qaïda nous protège parce
que malgré eux mais parce que c'est
l'arrêt c'est la réalité il faut essayer
d'imaginer ça un petit peu et on a
encore une fois à quel un acteur
politique qui a voulu négocier avec
québec a donc le régime précédent qui
négocier avec la junte donc il faut pas
imaginer que aujourd'hui il ya la junte
qui veut que la france partent al qaïda
qui veut que la france partent et les
russes dans l'équation donc on peut très
bien imaginer les russes amener
quelqu'un comme iliad agali le mettre
sur une table qui avant d'être chef
djihadiste est un notable et un
représentant touareg et dire vous voulez
parler avec bamako va parler voilà une
dalle on sort des accords d'alger et
nous on a mal la solution après dix ans
entre guillemets d'échec français faut
imaginer que les gens en face la france
n'agit pas dans le vide en fait ils ont
une stratégie cyril que vous ont dit les
militaires sur le terrain vous avez vu
tout récemment puisque vous revenait
tout juste du mali on l'a vu avec votre
reportage est ce que vous sentez un
désarroi j'ai dit vie si vous avez que
c'est la grande muette on n'en parle pas
évidemment mais il ya des contacts j'ai
pu faire là le transfert des trois
grandes bases du nord c'était premier
contact avec le mali j'étais à tessalit
tout je suis parti et que les derniers
avions avec une avec des soldats qui
étaient en immersion pendant cinq mois
en libye difficile à 50 km de la
frontière algérienne donc c'est pas des
conditions faciles avec des attaques
régulières et ensuite il ya eu autour
bouctou et kidal
aujourd'hui ce que je pourrais me
permettre de dire sans trahir ce qu'on
me dit à gao ou autre c'est qu'il ya
quand même un désarroi profond d'abord
parce que le on a le paradigme a changé
sans doute trop tard mais ça c'est pas
la faute de l'armée l'armée avaient
averti depuis longtemps qu'on avait fait
le tour de la faire enfin ça y avait des
avertissements plus haut sommet de
l'état major donc il ya eu le 10 juin
dernier le président français macron qui
tranche qui dit on va changer un peu de
paradigme est sans doute trop tard donc
un des arbres oui parce que quand on a
sur le terrain une force anti
djihadistes qui est très impliqué on
parle de milliers d'hommes et de femmes
qui sont sur le terrain quand même et
qu'on a le convoi 30,2 sur la voie
sacrée incombe wacom bien eu beaucoup
logistique c'était il ya un mois et demi
qui relie abidjan à gao via le burkina
faso et le niger et que ce convoi est
attaqué et conspué avec des drapeaux
français mais même drapeau qu'on a vu
dans ces manifestations des drapeaux
russe des drapeaux arrêter le génocide
mais cela ne comprennent pas et quand
ils sont arrivés au niger pays alliés il
ya eu une attaque en règle dans la zone
des trois frontières par des
manifestantes très agressive donc là il
ya un phénomène de choc et puis ces
attaques cette pression qui continue
comme vous le disiez parfaitement
puisque les affidés d'al-qaïda
administre maintenant font pas autre
chose dans plein d'endroits où il ya un
déficit absolue d'état quoi qu'en dise
le gouvernement de transition qui ce qui
qui se commet dire qui a beaucoup
d'arguments souverainiste mais ils ne
tiennent pas véritablement le pays donc
c'est pour finir la taxe sur gao il ya
une dizaine de jours où je rappelle qu'à
u15 en troisième mort c'était une
plusieurs tirs de mortier peut-être que
c'était un coup de chance qu'il ya
souvent des attaques mais là on dit que
le coup de chance le miracle c'est
qu'ils aient pas eu plus de victimes il
ya eu un mort il ya eu des blessés mais
on sent qu'il ya une pression qui
s'exerce et un manque je dirais et c'est
une litote de direction de la part du
politique où les soldats se retrouve
vraiment bouc émissaire ise et on le vit
très très mal quand on est engagé dans
une lutte comme ça où l'on meurt ou ont
des blessés sur un terrain depuis près
de dix ans et qu'on voit qu'une
population entière mais même au sahel
s'est retourné contre vous michel boyer
alors vu le retrait de la france qu'est
ce que ça va donner qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement cette base de gao
dont on vient de parler justement cyril
au mali faudrait kouassi suis moi pour
l'évacuer d ne serait ce que
concrètement c'est compliqué en terme de
temps quelles décisions en fait
politiques devraient prendre la france
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est rentré
dans la campagne présidentielle
aujourd'hui que beaucoup de gens
aujourd'hui demande un retrait de la
france pour l'instant la france dit
qu'elle veut continuer à lutter contre
le terrorisme comment qu'est ce qui va
se passer maintenant alors concrètement
l'opération marconne c'est plusieurs
implantations ce n'est pas que le mali
il ya une implantation très importante
au niger à niamey dans une base de
niamey où sept ans parlait d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui exactement le poste de
commandement il se trouve à djamena avec
là aussi une force aérienne et le plan
qui était en course était de transférer
toutes les forces qui se trouvait au
mali de l'aidant transfert fait
d'abandonner toutes les bases qui
étaient autour de ga'hoole passe
principal de la de donner ses bases aux
forces maliennes ou à la milice mains de
transférer toutes les forces françaises
au niger faire de nyamina mais pardon le
leur centre de gravité et de laisser au
mali dans la base de gao la force
takouba donc cette force européenne
encadrés par des français et qui étaient
destinés à accompagner les
les forces maliennes sur aujourd'hui
fragilisée par justement exactement
aujourd'hui très fragilisée et on
pourrait
pour se décider ça pourrait être un même
décision européenne collégiale dit robin
les forces européennes décide de se
retirer définitivement du mali c'est à
dire concrètement que taboo takouba se
retirer
du mali donc ce plan est-il caduque
aujourd'hui c'est non mais voilà ces
séances se dirigent sans doute vers ça
en réalité maintenant très concrètement
là aussi
la base de garros et des dizaines de
milliers de la faim des milliers de
conteneurs c'est c'est plusieurs
milliers de personnes c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on s'est incrusté
depuis des années et donc il faut
plusieurs bois de convois et chaque
convoi choc qu'on voit c'est une
opération militaire un signe dangereux
c'est long c'est donc il faudra des mois
dans tous les cas de figure il faudra
des mois pour évacuer tous non mois au
moins et non pas forcément mais au moins
quelques quelques manques ce sera après
après après l'élection présidentielle
dans tous les cas de figure mais après
quoi qu'il arrive si un vrai retrait
donc du mali et l'espace aérien malien
est à dix à la chasse française parce
qu'on a vu par exemple qui nourrit qui
dès qu'ils donnent beaucoup de mal et
que l'amisom a beaucoup de mal à voler
aujourd'hui les allemands de l'amusement
ont besoin d'une autre zone 36 heures au
préalable pourrait voler un drone donc
l'opération les l'utilité du drone n'est
plus donc si la chasse française ne peut
plus opérer dans le ciel malien tout
léopards laup passion barkan même si
effectivement normal comme ça c'est fait
l'essentiel terre la plus pour dire que
là aussi très concrètement la plupart
des gens que des djihadistes que nous
éliminons nous le faisons par le ciel
par les avions et par des drones armés
ça c'est peut-être 80% des djihadistes
qui sont qui sont éliminés ou part
éventuellement par des raids de forces
spéciales en hélicoptère et donc si le
ciel
on peut continuer le combat de cette
façon mais si le ciel malien est soumis
à autorisation simplement ça rend
extrêmement difficile ces opérations
sarah aussi extrêmement difficile le
fait d'aider l'armée malienne 1 c'est à
dire que les bataillons qui sont arrivés
à tessalit par exemple ils ont formé des
cours des contrôleurs aériens pour
pouvoir faire appel aux avions français
en cas de problème on reste quand même
la réserve cette force aérienne reste à
la réserve de l'armée malienne et donc
je pas sûr que des forces armées m les
militaires maliens soient très chaud
eux-mêmes pour interdire le ciel aux
français oui cyril justement un mot le
niger il connaît aussi est ce qu'il
pourrait justement être instable aussi
puisque les rares travers le niger mais
bon le niger était-il stable à ces
questions un million de dollars parce
que on compte beaucoup sur le digère
aujourd'hui vous le disiez parfaitement
il ya le ont repris mais la base
centrale de commandement pardon de
barkan à deux on la passe de djamena à
niamey mais il n'ya mais c'est pas non
plus le rêve absolu puisque il ya une
détérioration on l'a vu avec le convoi
qui avait été bloqué sur le sur le
terrain sur le propre politique une
hutte uva à une mysteries à sion aussi
lui débat dans l'opposition pour
haranguer la présence française donc ça
veut déstabiliser le président bazin qui
est un allié mais le problème c'est que
ces anneaux dernier les alliés et on en
avait cinq au départ et c'est à dire
extrêmement compliquée puisque le
burkina le burkina faso ne va pas nous
nous aider donc tout le concentré sur le
niger est un peu hasardeux d'autant plus
qu'on disait très justement si on mène
une guerre une guerre multilatéral
depuis un pays sans pouvoir survoler le
pays d'où il ya énormément de foyers
jihadistes ça va poser un problème donc
on est vraiment dans une dans une
équation un peu impossible mais qui
ressemble pour moi un piège et pour
avoir couvert la chute de kaboul quand
je revenais de l'afghanistan on disait
ça n'a strictement rien à voir puisque
barca n'a anticipé on va prendre de
temps et là on est dans une accélération
du temps quasi cauchemardesque pour les
observateurs pour les ceux qui ont
planifié tout ça et là je peux vous dire
je reviens de mac os ça ressemble un
petit peu à ça c'est un piège qui se
referme sur les français sur les
européens et je ne sais pas par quel
pays ou comment on va pouvoir s'en
sortir michel goya on pourra avoir
effectivement la france pourrait
reconnaître le fiasco afghans que
bayonne a aconnu n'en avait pas on ne
naît pas la précipitation du retrait
clou il ya une précipitation alors qui
est un peu il faut souligner aussi
peut-être les malheurs et ça de la
responsabilité de la france aussi un peu
dans cette dégradation
politique que dire des relations parent
soit en baisse depuis un certain temps
déjà quand quand la france en fin 2019
convoque la faim dans lequel on macron
annonce publiquement qu'il va convoquer
les les chefs d'état africains à pau
c'est très très mal perçu c'est un
camouflet toutes les déclarations là on
a renvoyé l'ambassadeur du mali ya deux
ans déjà suite à d un certain nombre de
déclarations les déclarations du
ministre des affaires étrangères l'a
aussi est-ce qu'elle était nécessaire de
rajouter de faire des déclarations
outrancières enfin très forte parce que
c'était nécessaire mais tout ça
contribue effectivement la dégradation
de la situation et nous a placés dans
une situation qui est maintenant très
compliqué
donc oui on se retire mais le combat
continue on sera présents au niger on
était présent aussi en côte d'ivoire là
encore des bases
d'ivoire par exemple est-ce que ça va
remettre en cause également la stratégie
française en côte d'ivoire est ce qu'il
risque d'avoir une sorte d'effet de
contagion aussi de l'internât c'est pas
les mêmes c'est dans les modes dynamique
après les djihadistes ça veut dire les
djihadistes déjà l'état islamique il est
il est qu'il est contenue aujourd'hui
sont trois frontières vivier on va dire
pour résumer vite le vivier de
recrutement et léo tillabéri au niger
vers le niger se base sur deux fronts le
front de différents contre l'état
islamique au lac tchad le front du
tillabéri contre l'état islamique au
sahel donc c'est une situation assez
assez particulière quand même pour le
président gbagbo mais pour les pays du
golfe de guinée il ya une volonté d'aqmi
de descente plus dans le sud mais encore
une fois pour faire court ils ont
l'ambition mais ils n'ont pas les moyens
les moyens humains c'est pas la volonté
qui manquent ils ont pas ils ont pas
d'unité assez disciplinés entre
guillemets pour reproduire ce qu'ils ont
fait au nord est et dans le centre donc
ça aussi ça peut faire partie 1 si on
réfléchit un peu frottement des choses
qui pourraient être négocié un parent
via un intermédiaire avec les
djihadistes gens vous voulez faire votre
votre
déjà les états locaux veulent négocier
avec eux donc déjà les laisser négocier
parce qu'eux aussi ont enfin les
épisodes diplomatique où les
représentant malien disait on veut
négocier avec elle j'ai dit c'est encore
de
oui mais c'est les premiers concernés
qui négocient finalement et finalement
quand on a les djihadistes qui disent on
veut négocier donc et il met un cadre au
conflit avec la france qui au mali au
cje parle du jeune homme en particulier
il se met des objectifs politiques
atteignable alors que la france est
paradoxalement c'est assez cocasse
enfermés dans les atlantes auteuil ce
qui est sans fin donc voilà donc si les
locaux veulent négocier avec eux et ils
le font déjà la france et a fait
obstruction donc peut-être qu'il faut
essayer aussi d'utiliser ce levier parce
que négociation n'est pas soumission et
c'est donnant donnant et peut-être
utiliser ce levier sera profitable pour
empêcher une descente plus au sud mais
c'est la fin d'une ère aujourd'hui c'est
non c'est la transformation
du néant passeront passe à quelque chose
d'autre mais le conflit continue à moins
de considérer que finalement cela n'a
pas d'importance on se bat quand même
rappeler parce que l'on considère que la
déstabilisation forte de la région
aurait des implications sur notre propre
sécurité
sur nos intérêts dans la région
notamment dans le golfe de guinée home
d'ivoire au sénégal et éventuellement en
europe de manière plus ou moins directe
donc le parti roman considère que le
problème est toujours là le combat
continuera mais sous d'autres formes
d'autres formes et difficilement merci
beaucoup cyril cyril payen merci voici
mois-ci menacera merci à vous et michel
goya d'avoir été avec nous ce soir et
merci à vous tous nos anciens